Speaker 1: You know, I have not
had the opportunity to watch
nearly enough of the Alex Jones defamation trial.
There's so much going on. Alex Jones is currently
in a defamation trial. His producer testified
and it was wacky. One of his other hosts,
Owen Shroyer, testified and was sort
of admonished by the judge for going
on air and talking about the trial, which he's
not supposed to be doing. It's been a cartoonish
fiasco. Alex Jones lawyer is really weird.
Everything about it is weird. We got a call
from in our voicemail line. That line is 2192.
David P from a viewer who agrees that this is
a really crazy trial. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: All right. I've pretty much watched
every minute of the Alex Jones trial
going on right now. And I would just
advise everyone to watch day four, which would
be Friday, July 29th, and watch The Last Witness.
I can't I don't know what her name is,
but she testifies about misinformation on
social media. And regardless of whether you
care or not about Alex Jones or anything,
everybody should watch her testimony. I think she
has testified about 2 hours now, and I think she's
coming back on Monday. So just check that out.
Speaker 1: I have heard about this.
I don't know what was said, but it sounds
absolutely fascinating. The trial is bonkers.
There's video of Alex Jones in what seems like a
nearby restaurant streaming, like during breaks
in the trial. There's video of Alex Jones
chain smoking cigarets outside the courthouse
and getting badgered by people who are walking
by. Every detail of this trial is bonkers. My
only regret is I've just been so busy, I haven't
been able to watch as much of it as I would like.
Check it out. Let me know your thoughts. We
have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 3: The bonus show where you want to
make money and everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Well,
speaking of Alex Jones, right.
Speaker 3: Thank your lucky
stars every day. You're not David Pakman.
Speaker 1: Many in our audience do on today's
bonus show. The House of Representatives
has passed and is now sending to the Senate
an assault style weapons ban. Will it go anywhere
in the Senate? The answer is, well, I think we
mostly know the answer. It's probably, you know,
J.D. Vance, who is the nominee for Ohio Senate,
whose name Donald Trump could not remember.
Speaker 3: We've endorsed J.P. like J.D. Mendell.
Speaker 1: No, no, no, no, no. That's J.D. Vance.
J.D. Vance running against Democrat Tim Ryan, who
I want to see what J.D. Vance is now saying.
Even if if a woman is in a violent marriage,
she should stay in it because divorce makes the
children unhappy. This is a conservative folks,
a pro-family conservative. We will talk about
it. And lastly, U.S. military run slot machines
earn $100 million per year from service members
overseas. The U.S. military is now running
casinos. This is not a new thing. I had no idea
that this was going on. But we will talk about
it on today's bonus show. How do you get access
to the bonus show? It's very easy. You go to join
Pacman dot com and you use the coupon code if you
want. Big voting 22 if you want. Okay. Up to you.
You don't have to take the discount. On tomorrow's
program, I will be joined by Roger Reeves. And
then on Thursday, I will be joined by Professor
Paul Slovic, who does really, really interesting
research on cognitive biases, heuristics,
risk value calculation. It sounds boring,
but I find it extraordinarily interesting, so I'm
looking forward to that as well. Bonus show today
shows all week. Livestreams upcoming. No shortage
of things happening. Thank you to everybody.